in this video i'm gonna make sure that
you don't
your first home buying experience with
these five simple tips as an architect
i've seen it all i've spent people spend
absurd amounts of money and still have
to spend wheelbarrows more to make sure
that it is livable and livable is a
pretty low standard of quality before
you even walk into your potential house
i want you to look left and i want you
to look right because if your neighbors
on either side of you or even on both
sides of you have dead grass this can be
a sure guaranteed way to realize what
the quality of that suburb is this
street quality example can be the
subject of discrimination unfortunately
it could lead to things as simple as
your local government not reinvesting
into that particular suburb or that
particular street it could lead into
higher break-in rates or it could even
lead to call-out fees being
significantly higher because trades
people don't want to come to that
particular suburb now did you bring your
phone charger because one you're gonna
need it to smash the like button do it
do it and two you're gonna need this
phone charger to basically go around and
be a complete dick about things and
check every single powerpoint in that
house and that's by simply going up to
every single war point plugging your
phone in and checking if your phone
lights up if it does you're good to go
but remember you genuinely have to be
quite obnoxious about this you have to
go into every single cupboard into every
single void and you have to turn on
every single light switch in the process
as well because an electrical fee and an
electrical call out to come and replace
the entire wiring of a house
could cost you a pretty substantial
amount now this tip is incredibly
annoying to everybody in that house but
it is a tip filled with bonus tips
inside so pay attention if you aren't
literally going around and hitting every
single wall as you're walking into that
house you're doing something wrong
because by going through the house and
hitting every single wall you're gonna
figure out one of three things first of
all you're going to figure out if it's a
brick or a framed house if it's a framed
house it can tell you if it's insulated
or it's not you're basically going to
hit that wall as hard as you can within
some reason so you don't punch hole in
it go and hit an exterior wall then come
back and hit an interior wall and i
guarantee you're going to know the
difference it also helps you understand
if there's any underlying basic
structural or water damage you probably
want to go out and hire somebody who's
going to do a full structural report on
the property anyway again inspecting a
home is going to make you seem like a
complete fruit loop swinging your hose
out in the front yard but since you
already have your hose in your hand you
might as well go and turn it on because
you're going to have to go outside close
every single door and every single
window and then literally just spray the
doors and windows for a good 10 to 20
seconds yes i understand this is a
complete waste of water i know but it's
not always going to be raining when
you're going to inspect your property
and if it's not raining you can't tell
if any of those doors or windows are
leaking i'll admit this last one is
exceptionally gross and even if you have
a stomach of steel it'll probably make
it turn i've heard some incredible
horror stories in my day but it's
something that you have to do so i need
you to go out find the chair find the
stepladder find anything that's going to
give you a little bit more height
because you're going to have to get up
into the hallway find the manhole push
that manhole up
very very slowly and find yourself with
a family of possums snakes mice or even
rats living up there next you want to
take out your phone once again because
you're going to need to smash the like
button before you turn on your flash to
actually check out what is up there at
the depths of the roof there could be a
nice little nest there could be a family
of rats and possums or it could be just
plain insulation which is perfect and
exactly what we're looking for and
that's it i'm david thomach see you next
time